wir schauen jetzt einmal ganz fokussiert
auf die militärische lage in der ukraine
und tun das wie gewohnt mit unserem bild
militärexperten julian rötker im
lagezentrum
[Musik]
ja auch heute geht die großoffensive der
russischen armee putins mega offensive
im osten der ukraine weiter wir wollen
uns einmal den aktuellen stand angucken
wollen uns angucken wo sind die rosen
vorgedrungen was haben sie geschafft und
wo wurden sie von den ukrainern zurück
zurückgedrängt und natürlich auch wie
machen dass beide seiten ganz genau
militärisch wir gucken uns noch mal ganz
kurz die übersicht lage an wir haben
also die die situation dass im osten der
ukraine nämlich in region raki flugangst
und donetzk unten und auch ein
satirischer eben ein russischer
offensive vorangeht die eben seit tagen
dieses dieses ziel hat hier wenn möglich
einen riesigen kessel zu erzeugen und
dort 30 bis 50.000 ukrainische soldaten
einzukesseln genau dafür wird vor allem
im norden geht die russische armee
weiter voran und wir gucken uns das ganz
normal aus der aus der nähe an dass wir
ein bisschen näher rankommen wichtige
orte sind einmal easy um hier nach ecke
von dort aus gehen die russischen
angriffe los und ebenso wie anzug und
krawatte internets das sind die letzten
beiden großen städten hierunter kann
greift unter kontrolle stehen und ebenso
donetzk und ein paar andere städte die
noch in der region so ganz unter
ukrainischer kontrolle stehen wir haben
neue bilder aus den letzten tagen da
haben russische truppen die stadt
cremona erobert kriminal eine 20.000
einwohner stadt in der region lugansk
wir sehen hier wie russische
propagandisten eben dort rein fahren in
die stadt hier vorne sehen wir dann auch
so zu sagen dass das ortsschild
und wir sehen wie sie in der stadt sind
natürlich werden dann wieder leute
interviewt das ist ganz normal in der
russische propaganda die immer sagen
vielen dank dass ihr in die nazis weg
sind und so weiter diese propaganda
kennt man schon was aber wichtig ist
sind eben die die städte wie man genießt
also sie haben tankstellen erobert sie
haben wohnhäuser erobert und sie haben
dass ist in dieser stadt zumindest so
relativ intakte wohngebiete erobert in
denen noch einige wenige menschen übrig
sind hier sind kleine häuser die dort zu
sehen sind hier sehen wir auch den
artillerie schaden von größeren gebäuden
und solche gebäude hier sind teilweise
noch ganz erhalten aber eben geister
steht dass die geister steht derweil so
gut wie niemand der einwohner hier unter
russischer herrschaft leben möchte man
darf er nie vergessen
2014 hat russland ein teil dieser region
so ganz und eroberte aus die sogenannten
volksrepublik gemacht und jeder der da
nicht leben wollte unter denen der ist
geflüchtet 1,5 millionen menschen sind
geflüchtet aus den gebieten die meisten
direkt hinter die sogenannte kontakt
linie die haben beispielsweise hier
gewohnt das heißt das sind menschen die
auch schon damals vor russland
geflüchtet sind niemals unter
sichtkontrolle leben wollten und nun
gibt es ja einige wenige ja die eben
bleiben die allermeisten sind weg diese
stadt hier kriminaloberrat worden von
der russischen armee vor wenigen tagen
die ukrainer versuchen wir gucken uns
das noch mal an wir versuchen hier
weiter dagegenzuhalten
criminale etwa hier neben sylvie banecki
sie um dort kriegen haben wir einen der
stärksten russischen angriffe der geht
etwa in die richtung nach süden und
versucht es nokia erst zu eroberten und
daneben sich mit den südlichen angriff
zu treffen und das ganze hier zu
schließen wir sehen uns mal an was die
ukraine geschafft haben sie haben
immerhin ein kleines dorf zurückerobert
hier hier sehen wir ukrainische soldaten
die vor einem zerstörten russischen
schützenpanzer vom typ bmw 2 stehen die
sind ja auch das kleine frau wo man
wiedererkennt dass das ein russischer
schützenpanzer ist und das ganze spielt
irgendwo im ort sei wo die ein kleines
dorf wo auch die russen versucht hatten
intrakey vorzudringen und zumindest
dieses kleine dorf wurde von den
ukrainern wieder befreit nachdem die
russen dort schon wir sehen uns hier mit
ihren schützenpanzern rhein gefahren
sind allgemein eine weiterhin extrem
schwierige lage für die ukraine die aber
auch verschiedene erfolge erzielen wir
gucken uns jetzt an ein video von
gestern hier sehen wir ich markiere das
einmal hier sehen wir einen weiteren
russischen kampfjets vom typ su 34 der
stürzten zu boden wurde also von einer
ukrainischen luftabwehr rakete getroffen
und wir bleiben einfach mal drauf und
gucken uns mal an wie die absturz das
ist nämlich relativ interessant er dreht
sich immer im kreis also im kreisel
artig und darin sehen wir dass eines der
beiden triebwerke offiziell
offensichtlich noch funktioniert also
noch schub auf einer seite existiert auf
der anderen seite nicht mehr trotzdem
das war nicht nur das flugzeug zu
überleben sozusagen das flugzeug weise
schwer beschädigt ist abgestürzt und
brennt dann hier und wir sehen jetzt
aber gleich noch das und das ist ganz
interessant erneut die beiden russischen
piloten sich noch retten konnten dh
diesen rausgesprungen jetzt geht die
kamera nach oben und wir sehen hier oben
kreises noch mal ein etwas besser sehen
hier ein fallschirm von einem der beiden
piloten auch der andere falsch und bis
zu sehen
bisschen schlechter und wir gehen
einfach mal wieder rauf und sehen wie er
zu boden geht und danach haben die
russen auch noch ein video
veröffentlicht wo sie eben gezeigt haben
dass sie die piloten evakuiert haben wir
sehen hier das brennende wrack und hier
sehen wir im extrem tiefflug einen
russischen hubschrauber der sich nähert
1 mi 8 hubschrauber der dort die beiden
piloten evakuiert die kurz neben dem
fragte sozusagen zu boden gegangen sind
wir wollen mal gucken wir haben gestern
gesehen das nicht zum ersten mal ein
russisches tanklager explodiert ist wir
gucken uns noch mal ganz kurz die sind
diesen angriff an der nacht und wir
hören vor allem mal rein und hören
gleich dieses geräusch was dort kurz vor
der explosion kommt
und zwar ungefähr jetzt und wir hören
dieses rauschen ja wir hören dass da
etwas sozusagen sich
und dass dann diese große explosion
kommt direkt danach und das spricht doch
sehr dafür dass es hier tatsächlich
einen angriff gegeben hat einen angriff
auf der luft wir können nicht genau
sagen von wo aber diese
überwachungskamera wir sehen uns da oben
die ganz normal lief zu der zeit um 217
lokalzeit die hat sozusagen dieses
geräusch aufgefangen von etwas was ich
wert kurz bevor der ex der explosion und
interessanterweise gab es gestern einen
weiteren vorfall eine region kursk dass
sein nachbar region auch in russland
direkt daneben und dort haben russische
hat das russische militär diese
aufnahmen hier veröffentlicht nämlich
aufnahmen einer abgestürzten bayraktar
tb2 drohne einer türkischen kampfdrohne
die ukraine einsetzt bisher wusste man
im krieg in der ukraine aber und das ist
spannend offenbar auch über russland das
heißt die ukraine hat mittlerweile auch
hier sehen wir noch mal den den dreizack
den ukrainischen hier oben sehen also
auch die die beschriftung der drohne und
können uns relativ sicher sein dass das
tatsächlich eine ukrainische drohne ist
die in kursk abgeschossen wurde von der
russischen armee kost auch ein an die
ukraine grenzen es gibt aber eben in
russland und offenbar gucken es noch mal
auf der großen karte an was wir gesagt
haben spielt alles hier im norden des
landes
brillanz ist ungefähr da kurs ungefähr
hier offenbar
reicht es der ukraine tatsächlich und
sie sagt wenn ihr jede nacht bei uns
angreift wenn ihr bei uns tanklager
zerstört wenn ihr bei uns mit an
flugzeugen mit einer raketen unsere
unsere eisenbahnstrecken zerstört dann
werden auch wir zurückschlagen und dann
werden auch wir unsere waffen einsetzen
unsere möglichkeiten einsetzen wie zum
beispiel diese bayraktar throne und
natürlich auch raketen um eben eure
nachschublinien der russischen armee in
russland zu treffen insofern extrem
spannend und so was hat man bisher noch
überhaupt nicht gewusst dass eben müssen
wir sind man kann aus diesen aus diesen
aufnahmen erahnen dass diese drohne
tatsächlich über russland im einsatz war
und über russland abgeschossen wurde
in dem war natürlich schlecht für die
drohne allerdings hat die ukraine mehr
als 50 davon und insofern kann es da
auch in der zukunft noch weitere
angriffe geben soviel zum aktuellen
stand der militäroffensive in der im
osten und der gesamte militär lage in
der ukraine
[Musik]
da gilt es bild lagezentrum zu julian
röcke